the second thing is how do I save well
what should I put my saving in and when
thinking about what you should put your
saving in realize that the least risk
investment that you think from
volatility is the least risk investment
is which is Cash is the worst investment
over a period of time and you could
judge that by judging the rate of
inflation in relationship to the after
tax income you're going to earn so if
you have an inflation rate that's two or
three percent and you're earning one
percent and you have to pay taxes on
that one percent or two percent that
you're going to get you're going to get
taxed essentially at two percent a year
and that's going to be a problem so you
have to move into assets and when you do
that the most important thing I can
convey to you is to diversify well
because I can guarantee you that one of
those assets and you won't be able to
pick the right one will be disastrous in
your lifetime that you will lose half of
that savings if you're in the wrong one
and you won't know what the right one is